[Música]
el conflicto armado en ucrania entra en
su noveno día con el avance de las
tropas rusas en territorio ucraniano la
situación se hace cada vez más tensa
ayer un ataque atribuido a rusia provocó
un incendio una planta nuclear de sap
orilla la más grande de europa el fuego
ya fue controlado por los bomberos pero
este hecho prendió las alarmas en la
comunidad internacional la oea la
agencia nuclear de la onu expresó su
profunda preocupación por la situación
de la planta y su director general
rafael grossi confirmó que no hay daño
en los reactores y no hay fugas
radioactivas además se ofreció a viajar
a ucrania el secretario de defensa del
reino unido- ben wallace pidió una
reunión urgente del consejo de seguridad
de naciones unidas por su parte moscú
niega la responsabilidad y atribuye a lo
que calificó como grupos de sabotaje
ucranianos esto ocurre mientras se
reúnen en bruselas los cancilleres de la
otan para así analizar las implicaciones
de la guerra y cuando no para la llegada
de cientos de miles de personas que
buscan refugio en europa en todo este
contexto
ayudamos entonces a nuestra primera
invitada a nada el paso analista
internacional y profesora de la
universidad complutense de madrid ana
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 preguntó
qué tan graves son estos ataques a las
centrales nucleares y cuáles son los
riesgos que implican
bueno buenas tardes en españa unos días
aquí es para mí un placer favor y allá
es la central nuclear más grande de
europa y tenemos que decir que es un
gran riesgo puesto que
sería un golpe muy fuerte si es así si
penetra los
núcleos de como hemos visto en japón
etcétera pues puede tener un accidente
nuclear importantes
consecuencias creo que putin lo que
quiere es
aislar energéticamente el país puesto
que esta central da el 30 por ciento de
capacidad de de recursos energéticos
a ucrania si tú cortas está este
subsidio de energía pues cortaste todo
el sustento al país y entonces le deja
sin recursos y lo que le preocupa a
cutting es que los civiles en los
militares que necesitan están
transmitiendo noticias y si se está
conectando por
por por teléfono y
por teléfono fundamentalmente por
telegram con todas las información para
organizarse
por las
todos los dos las operaciones que están
siendo
una rusia estaría jugando con fuego como
lo asegura reino unido
si están jugando bueno a ver putin no
hace nada sin que lo tenga bien
calculado no da pasos de ciego eso es lo
que tenemos que tener en cuenta por eso
lo que para nosotros nos parece una
pista que en nueve días de conflicto
armado o de guerra
está haciendo pasado todas las noticias
demasiado rápidas pero no no es así
tampoco él quería una guerra relámpago
tampoco es cierto porque hay resistencia
en ucrania entonces esto esto está más
está sucediendo más despacio porque él
no él quiere andar sobre seguro entonces
sí sí puede haber una una solución una
vía de escape a la desesperada
o sea no no es nada descartable no creo
hombres no creo que no lo creo que haya
una una tercera guerra mundial pero él
si va a ir a por todas y va a ir a por
todas ucrania eso no lo descarto en
absoluto
anna hoy también se reúnen en bruselas
los cancilleres de la otan qué medida se
puede tomar esta alianza para tratar de
frenar la guerra
la otan ha quedado ha dejado bastante
claro desde el principio y precisamente
para no entrar en una tercera guerra
mundial que no va a abrir un conflicto
otan-rusia
de acuerdo entonces él
y todos los ministros hoy
resolverán el potencial en los flancos
que con los países de la otan que son
vecinos con rusia como están haciendo
sobre todo van
supongo yo también qué
rumanía con la frontera con
moldavia que no es de la otan y por
supuesto van no van a enviar ni tropas a
frenar ni aviones de la otan ni nada
parecido pero sí que van a enviar ayuda
humanitaria
como hemos visto en misiones
humanitarias en otros países que es así
por donde por dónde se empieza la
participación otan con misiones
humanitarias en el flanco que donde país
o tal que están franquistas con un rusia
con ucrania verdad ahora a no no quiero
despedir nuestra conversación sin hablar
de otra arista de este conflicto además
como la más cruel no y hablo obviamente
de los refugiados las personas que huyen
de esta guerra ya acnur ha estimado que
son más de un millón de personas y
cientos de miles son las que siguen su
camino hacia los países sobre todo
europeos o para huir de este conflicto
además lo ms expresó su preocupación por
la vulnerabilidad
a estas personas a las enfermedades
sobre todo también en invierno y que
afectaría sobre todo a los niños qué
podemos esperar este fin de semana a na
vamos a no esto no va a ser esto va a
ser un sitiados pero a medida que no va
a ser un millón va a ser más tres
millones por lo menos los de exagerando
son últimas
últimos cálculos de acnur no va a ser
una guerra de 123 meses tampoco a medida
que el desplazamiento de los refugiados
gracias a la unión europea se les va a
dar un año para que un año para que se
trabajen y
se adapten al sistema de medio médico
educativo etcétera
esto es para evitar que los campos de
refugiados en las zonas fronterizas esto
ha sido una decisión histórica bien pero
también se están en el tema del comit
que no es no hay que dejarlo en otro
papel de olvidar y al mismo tiempo que
se están adaptando según me cuenta cruz
roja internacional y a color al mismo
tiempo que se están
dando la bienvenida y acogiendo a estos
refugiados se están tomando las medidas
para
para el cob y vacunándolos etcétera
entonces vas es una operación única
histórica desde la segunda guerra
mundial acogerles
y ser atendidos y ser adaptados
médicamente para que no se recupere para
no tener los problemas que afronta el
mismo tiempo